il y a des trucs marrants comme ça
par exemple les diplomates français ici
si les satellites sont vaccinés et qu'ils peuvent
voyager la plupart des pays et les nôtres
diplomates à paris compagnons vaccinés et
ils ne peuvent pas aller au restaurant
nulle part et je suis devenu très ami avec
mon collègue de saint marin
un petit pays mais ils sont entièrement
est apparu comme un satellite et s'y rend même avec
le tourisme médical comme on dit
autour des vaccins à la cire par le tourisme italien
mais ils sont avec eux tous leurs certificats
vue satellite ils vont tranquillement en italie et
d'Italie plus loin, apparemment il y a déjà des frontières
il n'y en a pas pour l'Union européenne et je suis parti pour
temps d'août et a demandé à Luigi de
miami des affaires étrangères
le même vaccin la même espèce x
figures humanoïdes du rivage et pour une raison non
se transforme en un bouton nous pensions que nous
probablement en novembre nous interdirons le sun marine
pour me conduire, c'est-à-dire que c'est encore une logique
vice versa